In Sri Lanka, a tropical island nation just
a few miles southeast of India, children never
get a snow day.
Neither do they have to contend with earthquakes,
volcanoes, or sandstorms.
But three million of its students now face
a different kind of disaster: their schools
can’t afford ink — or even paper on which
to print it.
On March 19th, the education department of
its largest province announced the cancellation
of all exams for grades 9, 10, and 11 for
that exact reason.
Today, however, paper is the least of its
concerns, as entire cities grind, as we speak,
to a dangerous and unprecedented halt.
Prices for essential goods — everything
from rice to fuel to medicine — have doubled,
then tripled, and continued rising.
That, combined with power outages lasting
up to 15 hours a day, have Christian nuns,
Hindus, Muslims, and Buddhist monks, who just
10 years ago fought each other in a Civil
War, all joining hands on the streets in protest.
Unfortunately, the worst is likely yet to
come.
As the last remaining supplies dwindle away,
the current 9-hours of electricity and severely
overpriced groceries may soon be remembered
as the “good days”.
And yet, Sri Lanka, experts warn, is just
the tip of the iceberg.
Though unique as a country, the roots of many
of its current problems are far too common.
The United Nations warned last month of a
“perfect storm” brewing in the developing
world.
One expected to leave, quote, “deep and
long-lasting scars”.
Sri Lanka, in other words, may simply be the
first domino to fall this year.
And understanding how it got here — unable
to afford even paper — may offer a preview
of what comes next.
Sponsored by Storyblocks, where you can find
over a million high-quality videos for your
creative projects, business, or, like us,
YouTube channel.
This is an imaginary country.
If it imports more “things” than it exports,
we say it has a “trade deficit”.
Conversely, if it exports more than it imports,
it has a “trade surplus”.
Now, because our frame of reference is personal
finance, in which you’re told to spend less
than you save, or corporations, where “profit”
sounds a lot like a “surplus” of money,
it’s tempting to see deficits as a bad thing.
Of course, as you may already know, it’s
much more complicated.
The United States, for instance, has a huge
deficit.
The slower-growing Japanese economy, meanwhile,
has a giant surplus.
But what’s all too easy to forget is that
the U.S., and, to a lesser extent, Japan,
are weird countries.
China may “win” the trade war with the
U.S., for example, but what does it do with
all that money?
Invest in the United States!
But, remember, this is a very unique set of
circumstances.
It’s what economists mean when they say
the U.S. has a “privileged position”.
When China sells things to America, it wants
to buy, with that money, U.S. dollars, not
Somali shillings or Iraqi Dinars!
…Or Sri Lankan rupees.
To see why this is an issue for a country
like Sri Lanka, stop thinking in terms of
imports versus exports and, for the sake of
simplicity, think instead about the actual,
physical supply of Dollars.
When it buys, say, milk, from next door India,
it generally pays for those goods with U.S.
Dollars because that’s what India wants.
Likewise, when Sri Lanka sells its tea to
the U.K., the British pay it in Dollars.
You should start noticing two potential problems
here.
First, if a country imports more than it exports,
you can see how it could just run out of USD
— it would be effectively spending more
than it’s saving.
And second, running out of USD is problematic
because it’s what you need to buy imports.
In other words, for countries not named “the
United States of America”, this balance
of payments really is important.
Here, where a negative value equals a trade
deficit, you can see that Sri Lanka has been
“in the red”, so to speak, for quite some
time.
It imports a huge amount of rice, wheat, sugar,
and medicine — not to mention all its oil.
Now, all this might sound like trade deficits
are some horrible, no-good, very bad thing.
But, as you can see here, most countries run
deficits.
There’s nothing rare or necessarily catastrophic
about having a negative balance of trade on
its own.
What all these countries do to make up the
difference is simply borrow.
If that sounds unsustainable, well, yes and
no.
In the case of Sri Lanka, its government has
a long history of gross mismanagement.
Just last year, for example, the government
banned the import of all chemical fertilizers
in a bid to become the world’s first “all-organic”
nation.
To the surprise of no one but the president,
crop yields were immediately cut in half.
You could make a pretty good case that Sri
Lanka was destined for a crisis of some kind
and that it was only a matter of when.
Yet, just a few short years ago, the country
showed real economic promise.
It had other ways of getting its hands on
Dollars.
In 2019 tourism accounted for 22% of its total
GDP.
Lonely Planet ranked the country the number
one best place to visit that same year.
There are beautiful beaches, wild leopards,
yoga retreats, and stunning natural landscapes.
Another source of foreign exchange was remittances.
Workers would go overseas, earn foreign currency,
and send it to their families back home.
But… you can probably guess what happened
in 2020.
Tourism effectively fell to zero overnight.
Actually, the decline in tourists began even
before the pandemic.
In the Spring of 2019, terrorists bombed a
string of churches and hotels across the capital,
Colombo.
The tragic and shocking death of 269 people
— at least 45 of which were foreign nationals
— led to a 70% drop in tourist arrivals.
Its $7.9 billion of foreign reserves in 2019
fell to just $1.6 billion by 2021.
And if that sounds bad, there's an extra reason,
on top of the normal badness, that makes it
even worse.
You may have heard that some countries intentionally
under or over-value their currencies.
Sri Lanka is one of those places.
Let’s say a bag of rice from India costs
one USD to import, and one USD is currently
worth 200 Sri Lankan rupees.
If Sri Lanka can convince everyone that, “no,
actually 150 rupees is the value of a U.S.
Dollar”, well now that rice is effectively
25% cheaper.
The Central Bank, in other words, overvalued
the rupee because the country depends so heavily
on imports.
By keeping staple goods affordable, authorities
in developing nations maintain economic, and
therefore, political stability.
If you’re wondering why all countries don’t
do this, the answer is what Sri Lanka is going
through now.
Actually maintaining that artificial exchange
rate involves buying and selling — or borrowing
— foreign currency, which, remember, Sri
Lanka is running out of.
Here you can see where the central bank kept
the rupee at roughly the same value until
it suddenly couldn’t, when it's real, market
value took over.
The government, meanwhile, was still pretending
that 1 USD was worth, for example, 150 rupees,
when everyone else had decided it was worth
200.
Here’s what that means in practice: Walk
into a bank, hand them one USD and they’ll
give you back 150 rupees.
Walk, on the other hand, into a private shop,
hand them that same dollar bill, and they’ll
give you, say, 200.
It doesn’t take long before word gets out:
don’t deposit your foreign currency in the
bank — “it’s a scam”.
Migrant workers quickly learned not to send
their remittances home through official channels.
Because of this, the central bank has even
less foreign currency, making it even harder
to maintain its fake exchange rate.
And this is when things get really ugly, really
fast.
What Sri Lanka is experiencing now are the
effects of three, interconnected problems.
First, because the country is running out
of Dollars, it can’t buy enough imports
to keep up with demand — meaning there just
isn’t enough rice, paper, or fuel to go
around.
Second, at the same time, people’s savings
are suddenly worth far less today than they
were yesterday.
Years of hard work — gone overnight.
And third, not only is the Rupee rapidly depreciating
in value, but no one knows where, exactly,
the bottom is.
It doesn’t take a rocket scientist to see
the trend.
Last week I could afford a dozen bananas.
Today, half as many.
Every rational household starts stocking up
on essential goods — leading to chaos, confusion,
and chronic undersupply.
Lines at gas stations were so long that two
men collapsed and died waiting.
Needless to say, the pandemic plus poor governance
had placed the country on tenuous ground already.
Then the war in Ukraine began.
The conflict and the subsequent sanctions
are currently causing the largest commodity
shock in half a century.
Here you can see, for instance, the price
— and just as importantly, its volatility
— of wheat and maize, which Russia and Ukraine
produce 28 and 15% of the global supply of,
respectively.
Ukrainian exports alone previously fed 400
million people.
Some countries get nearly all their wheat
from one or both.
These are just the places which source at
least 80% of their wheat from Russia and Ukraine.
On top of this, Russia also supplies 15% of
the world’s fertilizer, and, just as importantly,
the fuel used to make fertilizer.
If you drive a car and live on planet Earth,
you probably don’t need to be told that
oil prices are off the charts.
Many countries have or will react by banning
food exports — further exacerbating the
situation for net importers like Sri Lanka.
Now, like trade deficits, developing countries
being unable to pay back their loans is not
all that uncommon.
There’s a system for this sort of thing
— the equivalent of “bankruptcy” for
nations.
Normally, organizations like the IMF and World
Bank step in.
Sri Lanka last received a bail-out from the
IMF for $1.6 billion in 2016.
But this time is different.
Bail-outs, you see, are conditional on things
like having a functional government and implementing
economic policies which are often unpopular.
The IMF doesn’t just write checks on a whim
— it wants to know that the country won’t
end up in the same situation 6 months later.
These are conditions Sri Lanka simply can’t
meet.
While citizens are very justifiably angry
at their government, the unfortunate truth
is that political turmoil and social unrest
will likely only discourage foreign assistance.
Protestors are right that the country’s
economic woes didn’t come from nowhere.
The groundwork for the current crisis can
be traced back decades — when Sri Lanka
began paying off old loans with new ones,
in what the World Bank has compared to a Pyramid
scheme.
While it’s easy to connect the dots between
an unprecedented global pandemic and a sudden
economic collapse, so too is it easy to blame
Chinese loans, but neither theory captures
the whole truth.
Only about 10% of Sri Lanka’s debt is owned
by China, and its leaders have been pursuing
disastrous policies for years before any of
the recent events.
In 2019, it cut taxes precisely when it needed
public revenue the most.
Poor governance is not the only but it is
an important ingredient to the cocktail of
calamities it’s dealing with now.
What’s surprising is not Sri Lanka’s poor
leadership, but how quickly it all unraveled.
In a matter of weeks, millions of Sri Lankans
went from living a fairly middle-class lifestyle
— cars, college education, and leisure — to
wondering whether they can eat dinner.
This is how countries spiral out of control.
A shock, or, in this case, a trifecta of shocks,
exposes a nation’s weak governance.
From there, there’s no limit to how bad
things can get.
For which other country or countries will
the confluence of the pandemic, financial
tightening, and a drastic increase in commodity
prices soon expose a weak foundation?
When the Fed raises interest rates, as it’s
doing now, developing countries have a harder
time paying off their loans.
This requires that they choose between servicing
their debt or spending what little money they
have saving lives at home.
Some experts are pointing to Pakistan — whose
currency is currently in rapid decline — as
a possible next domino to fall.
This domino, however, is nuclear.
The war alone is expected to decrease global
GDP growth by 1% this year.
Put simply: a global pandemic, a change in
interest rates, and the largest armed conflict
in Europe since the Cold War, would each,
by themselves, be hugely significant.
But all three at the same time?
That’s why the UN calls this a “perfect
storm”.
Here you can see the last 15 years of agriculture,
commodity, and grain prices.
While high prices don’t guarantee social
unrest, they tend to correlate.
This, for example, is the Arab Spring.
This, meanwhile, is where prices were before
the war in Ukraine.
This is where they’re at now.
What for the rich world will be an inconvenience
— high gas prices, inefficient supply chains,
and, possibly, even recession, will, for the
developing world, mean the undoing of decades
worth of progress in healthcare, education,
and general prosperity.
Now, you may be wondering why Sri Lanka has
been the focus of this video, when this is
really a global issue.
The reason is simple: What’s happening in
Sri Lanka is tragic, visible, and all too
real — which makes it a useful way of humanizing
what are, ultimately, numbers on a graph.
And that’s why I love Storyblocks.
Video, in my opinion, is the most compelling
method of storytelling.
Many of the clips you saw in this video, including
the ones you see on screen now, were sourced
from Storyblock’s collection of over a million
clips.
We found 28 pages of video from Sri Lanka
alone.
What I love about YouTube is that it reduces
the barriers to creativity — anyone can
tell a compelling story.
Storyblocks, likewise, does that for video
clips.
Most stock video costs $50, 75, $100 per clip.
Storyblocks costs a fraction of that and gives
you access to unlimited downloads of its entire
collection.
I just checked my email and it turns out I’ve
been using Storyblocks now for four years.
I was already recommending it before they
became a sponsor.
So, whether you’re a solo entrepreneur,
an aspiring filmmaker, YouTuber, or business
professional, Storyblocks is the go-to resource
for quick, easy to find, and high-quality
video.
Click the link on screen now or in the description
and sign up for their Unlimited All access
plan today.